Gemeinsam packen sie an,
um die Schäden der Flut zu beseitigen.
Die Solidarität ist groß in Deutschland.
Trotz der Covid-Pandemie kommen
freiwillige Helfer aus dem ganzen Land
in die überschwemmten Gebiete -
wie hier nach Ahrweiler in Rheinland-Pfalz.
Abstand halten,
Maske tragen,
daran ist gar nicht zu denken.
Man hat jetzt schon oft gehört, dass Covid
einfach durch diese Flut weggespült wurde.
Das würde eher alles behindern
und die Leute noch mehr frustrieren,
wenn sie auch noch
bei den Abräumarbeiten auf Abstände
und so Sachen achten müssten.
Momentan denkt, glaube ich,
gar keiner grad über Covid nach.
Weil, wir müssen erst mal zusehen, dass wir
die Leute, die hier ihr Haus verloren …
Viele haben ja gar nix mehr, gar nix.
Hier waren … Ex … viele Existenzen,
die einfach weg sind,
Wohnungen, die zeitgleich weg sind.
Da wird [sich] jetzt nur noch drum gekümmert,
dass die Leute irgendwie
irgendwo heile unterkommen.
In der Notunterkunft stehen
die Betten dicht an dicht.
Tagsüber leer, aber die Nacht
verbringen obdachlose Anwohner
und ihre Helfer hier
auf engem Raum zusammen.
Ein möglicher Covid-Hotspot,
aber das Infektionsrisiko beschäftigt
die Menschen hier kaum.
Man merkt einfach,
denen geht’s um Leben und Tod.
Die haben alles verloren.
Da ist Corona nicht das Thema
für diese Menschen.
Und wir wollen uns auch nicht zumuten,
da zu sehr einzugreifen.
Weil - die Leute sind traumatisiert,
von dem was sie erlebt haben.
Und da können … da steht’s uns auch
einfach nicht zu zu sagen:
„Aha, jetzt aber bitte
die AHA-Regeln beachten.“
Erst das Unwetter mit den Sturzfluten
und der massiven Zerstörung
und jetzt wird befürchtet,
dass sich Covid hier verstärkt ausbreitet.
Um dem vorzubeugen, ist in Ahrweiler eine
mobile Test- und Impfstation angekommen.
Die Infrastruktur wurde zerstört.
Das Impfmobil wird erst mal
weiter zur Verfügung stehen.
Man muss auf eine sehr
feinfühlige Art und Weise der Bevölkerung
hier ’n bisschen nahebringen,
dass ihnen zwar alles weggeschwommen ist,
aber dummerweise dieses Virus nicht.
Knapp die Hälfte der Deutschen ist
inzwischen vollständig geimpft.
Aber die Delta-Variante
ist auf dem Vormarsch.
Die Organisatoren hoffen, dass viele das
Impf-Angebot noch wahrnehmen.
Doch einige Bewohner sind skeptisch.
Ich bin schon geimpft, schon länger.
Aber viele Leute, die ich kenne,
die sind nicht geimpft,
und die haben jetzt keine Zeit.
Die haben gesagt:
Was soll ich, warum soll ich jetzt impfen?
Ich habe jetzt zu tun, [anderes] als zu impfen.
Sagen: Impfen ist nicht [so] wichtig wie das.
In diesem Chaos
auch noch Covid zu bekämpfen –
eine Herausforderung,
kaum zu bewältigen.